roll the dice or go all the way by
Charles Bukowski if you're going to try
go all the way otherwise don't even
start if you're going to try go all the
way this could mean losing girlfriends
wise relatives jobs and maybe your mind
go all the way it can mean not eating
for three or four days it could mean
freezing and a park bench
it can mean jail it can mean division
mockery isolation isolation is the gift
all the others are a test of your
endurance how much you really want to do
it and you'll do it despite rejection
and the worst odds and it'll be better
than anything you can imagine if you're
going to try go all the way there's no
other feeling like that you'll be alone
with the gods and the nights will flame
with fire do it do it all the way all
the way you will ride life straight to
perfect laughter it's the only good
fight there is
you